uh good afternoon everyone and welcome
to today's planning committee
meeting uh here in the new
chamber we have uh three applications on
the agenda along with the report on
planning appeals we will also be
reviewing an appeal decision which will
be taken on an exempt side of the agenda
uh I am happy with this and intend to
take the business in order set out on
the agenda just a reminder that once
committee has gone into exempt session
the YouTube stream will end and any
public still in the room will be asked
to
leave the first item is apologies for
absence have we received any non receive
chair thank
you the second item is Declaration of
Interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interest and any
or other interest not already on their
register of interest in any item on the
agenda and withdraw from the meeting at
that appropriate time do any members
have any interest to
declare yes
coun I'm aware uh that councelor Lacy my
wife had posted a message on Facebook uh
supporting the planning application in
relation to the change of use from a
retail shop to a micro Pub I have not
taken part in or in any of the support
for the application or otherwise and I
intend to participate in the
method thank
you uh we now the minutes of the last
meeting uh on Tuesday 7th of no November
are we happy they are a correct record
and can we agree them by acclamation
chair just on on page four um it's
saying that Council of force it was
substituted by myself when actually I'm
an actual member of this committee so
right so I there's somebody else whose
name should have been there
instead right Amendment have we got a
move yeah thank you I'll second chair
and just take a
v thank you that's agreed
thank you
members that brings us uh up to the main
business for meeting are three
applications before we start I would
like to to explain for the benefit of
members and speakers and those watching
on
YouTube how we will deal with
them thank you chair this is the
procedure of considering the business
this
afternoon the chair will introduc an
application they ask the planning
officers to refer members to any late
comments or updates received since the
agenda was
issued these have been published on
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to
you after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting there
are eight speakers today and there will
be speaking on all three
applications they will each have three
minutes to put forward their
views there will be a reminder given by
the clock when 30 seconds remain at the
end of the 3 minutes members of the
committee will have an opportunity to
ask the speaker questions if necessary
to clarify any points that they have
made after the speakers addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting but they will not be allowed
to participate further from this
Bo the chair will open up the meeting
for questions to officers debate by the
committee and finally determination on
the application by a vote the vote will
be taken using the new voting facilities
on your
microphones finally members this meeting
is being live streamed and a recording
will be placed on the council's
website please note thats may choose to
copy this recording thank you
ch
let's move to the first application Ned
96l uh I'm going to read out the full
details on this but it's a new
development comprising of 38 new new
homes
Aton in line with our normal practices
I'm going to ask the planning offices to
give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site I will
allow officer to complete the
presentation consequently members unless
you have a point of order you feel
cannot wait could you please reserve
these or any questions about the process
until the end so I'm now going to end
you over to Phil Slater who's going to
give our first presentation thank
you thank you CH members willed a late
representation from councelor Dale that
was sent yesterday afternoon as all
members have received this we haven't
summarized content C refers to the
policy lc3 and issues Pary High safety
are discussed within the committee
report a further representation has been
received from the local president
raising concerns in relation to the
housing need the design and impact of
the
school this is a 100% affordable housing
scheme for 38 dwellings for rental and
shared ownership proposals include two
bed three bed and wheelchair accessible
homes with 50 c parking
spaces as set out in the committee
report officers have concluded the
scheme meets the provisions for limited
affordable housing in the green belt
that it meets the criteria as an
exception side for affordable housing as
set out in policy lc3 the local plan it
is concluded that the proposal is not
inappropriate in greenb terms and so
acceptable in
principle application site is a
Greenfield site in the center of the
screen which sits between hon Junior
school and garden center the S slopes
from the main road down to the Bel trees
at the top of the screen is uning Crow
and miners Cottages which are referred
to in the
report this show was the red
line the yellow line is a safeguarded
landine for education on policy
id6
this is a layout of proposed 38 units
these are arranged in three teres to
take advantage of the levels and Orient
to provide solar game the three teres
step down the hill and Terrace one and
2A would be visible from the main road
Landscaping
on and off again there seems to be a
gremlin
there
better landscaping and tree tree
planting are proposed within the
side space to the rear of Terrace 2 all
plots have secure cycle storage 50
parking spaces are provided and these
will be off plot with the exception of
the two wheelchair accessible glows on
terce to high author confirm that they
have no objections to the parking
numbers
perers level pedestrian access is shown
in the northeast corner to allow access
to teres one and two two Bungalow are on
Terrace 2 and two apartments both each
end G retaining walls on which planted
to allow vegetation to grow between
Terrace 2 and Terrace 3 is a commun open
space which provides trees and
attractive
PL
start
is this is this better
yes
I would suggest if we have this sort
book start it from beginning again from
from the very beginning
okay and the appli site is in the C
SC
[Music]
at top of the screen Ison Crow Lane and
minus costes which I referred to in the
report this shows the red line side
boundary the yellow line is a
safeguarded land for education on the
policy
id6 this is a layout of the proposed 38
units these are arranged in three
territor to take advantage of the levels
and orientated to provide solar
gain the three terrs step down the hill
and Terrace one and 2A will be visible
from the main road landscaping and tree
planting up POS within the S and public
open space to the rear of Terrace 2 all
plots have secure cycle
storage 50 parking spaces are provided
and these will be off plot with the
exception of the two wheelchair
accessible glows on Terrace 2 the
highway Authority have confirmed that
they have no objections to the parking
numbers
proposed leval pedestrian access is
shown in the northwest corner to allow
access to terrorist one and
two gabian retaining walls are proposed
which will be planted to allow
vegetation to grow between Terrace 2 and
three as a communal open space which
provides trees and interactive play to
the rear of Terrace 3 the site boundary
is a gaban ranium wall and Beyond is the
education safeguarded
land this shows the proposed new access
onto Main Road the new layby and bus
stop and the new pedestrian
access the existing wall will be
retained apart from the gaps of the new
accessors the plan shows visibility
spays from both the access and the
garden
center
this is a street elevation from Main
Road it's crosssections showing the
three Terraces stepping down the slope
in sight there are retaining gabing
walls to the rear of Terrace 2 which
overlooks public open space which then
drops down to car parking at Terrace 3
this also shows that the scheme meets
the design guidance in respect of
Separation distances and
overlooking uh these are the elevations
of Terrace one the bottom is the
elevation that will face onto Main Road
these are split level
units this is half of Terrace 2 the
other half is a mirror of this the end
units are two B apartments and the
bungalows in the
middle this is a view of the bus stop
and the location of the new access the
wall will be largely be retained apart
from the new access and a pest estrian
access A View from the bus stop looking
toward looking north towards drum field
access is where the bus lby
is a view from the propos access looking
South towards the unon garden
center A View From next to the Garden
Center entrance Terrace one will
partially be visible above the
wall
It's A View From Within the site looking
down to the east the bottom part of the
field would be the safeguard that land
for Education the trees at the bottom
lie outside of the site and the school
lies beyond the Hedge to the
left this is an extract of the landscape
report taken from the miner's Cottage
and showing the Garden Center building
in the
school this is a photo taken from
Morland view appol the site can be seen
in the center of the screen next to the
Garden Center
buildings thank you
chair thank
you uh right colleagues we have uh five
speakers on the application the first of
which is local Ward member councilor
Alex Dale uh and objector uh they will
each have three minutes to get over
their points and will'll be informed
when 30 seconds remain as members you
can ask ask them to clarify by any
matters that they have raised but
remember your questions should relate to
the points which they have already
made so uh over to Count
Council thank you chair firstly I cannot
emphasize enough uh the significance of
the decision before you today not just
for the village of unon but for the
district as a whole and the far-reaching
ramifications it will have as the site
sits outside of the unone settlement
development limits and within the green
belt it would in normal circumstances be
considered inappropriate development and
be rejected outright instead policy lc3
is being relied upon to demonstrate an
exceptional case to permit
development but the word the policy
wording is clear that all five of its
tests must be met in order for it to
apply so if you have any doubts that any
single one has not been adequately
demonstrated then I strongly urge you to
vote to reject this application myself
and the other speakers have coordinated
ourselves to avoid repetition and we
will be asking you to carefully consider
whether this scheme is is seeking to
meet genuine local community needs or
more than that whether alternative sites
and options have been truly exhausted
whether the proposals are in keeping
with the village and local landscape and
whether 38 new homes in a small village
could ever constitute a limited scheme
in relation to the first point in
particular I emplore you to very
carefully consider the policy wording
for lc3a in the local plan it makes
clear that to be an exception site a
proven need must be confirmed or
supported by a local needs housing Sur
local housing needs survey that is
simply just not the case here as the
survey conducted concluded that there
was an identified need for just seven
properties not the 38 we have in front
of us today and if you read the exact
policy wording it simply does not allow
for the shifting of goalposts and the
layering on of additional information
from housing officers to fill the Gap
and in any case the extra information
that housing officers are provided still
doesn't stand up to scrutiny because
it's indicative of a broader District at
wide demand and the desirability of un
as a place to live rather than genuine
proven local community needs if if we
follow the policy wording to the letter
then the test lc3a sets has clearly not
been met you have to ask yourselves
whether this scheme is seeking to meet
the genuine proven needs of unon or the
demands and desires of the district as a
whole if you have any doubts remain
thank you if you have any doubts that it
may be the latter then I urge you to
vote to refuse the application for
non-compliance with this policy if we
allow this scheme to be approved we'll
be setting a dangerous precedent where
settlement development limit in highly
sought after or desirable communities
become effectively meaningless in the
face of an Open Season from
opportunistic Developers for the sake of
the district as a whole please reject
this application today thank you
chair thank you Council Dale has anybody
got any questions for Council Dale
Council
Foster
yeah thank thank you very much CH the
the so in terms of the the obviously the
local um housing needs survey
demonstrated a need for seven and then
the developer goes on to say that well
not all not all the residents who
received the survey returned it so
therefore you can extrapolate up the
results of that so implication but
implication there is that uh we're sort
of you know that people who didn't
respond uh are represented by the people
who did and therefore that there is a
need there that actually isn't there in
my opinion I in my opinion if there was
a need people would have responded to
the survey and that's how that should be
treated and in addition to that they
then pick on three particular figures
from our hous uh housing uh strategy
team one of them is that 174 affordable
homes are required per anom within
Northeast arer that figure is a
district-wide figure so doesn't relate
to local community needs in my opinion
uh and uh that figure was also being met
by the fact that we have a local plan
which allocates 330 houses uh per anom
anyway uh the second figure they rely on
is the 259 bids on seven properties in
unon uh within the last year uh now
again that figure is for all of
Northeast arire that's that's people
from across the district who are
applying for properties that come up
within unon it doesn't necessarily
indicate a local community need from
unon itself and actually also if you
look at the way that our housing list
system works if you are on uh if you are
applying for housing and you have a
priority banding you are actively
encourag to apply for as many properties
as you possibly can because if you don't
apply for properties that are suitable
to meet your needs you have the risk of
being reduced in terms of that priority
banding so I think that that figure uh
doesn't hold up to scrutiny either and
then finally the 500 applicants on the
housing list who have a registered local
connection I've done some digging on
this figure and actually from an email I
received from the housing strategy this
morning I was really surprised to see
that that local connection does not just
relate to won so the 500 applicants that
they're talking about there are from a
much bigger area or have a local
connection to a much bigger area which
includes unon Parish but also all of
drumf Parish so drum field Woodhouse
drumf Co Aon gossi Valley and all of
aington parish as well so that's
eckington uh Ridgeway renishaw Marsh
Lane a much much bigger area to have a
local connection to now if you if you
compare Hon's population to the
population of that broader area
including drum field and eckington it's
only 5% so if you if you actually cut
that figure down that 500 people with a
local connection only 5% of that it's
it's it's fair to assume would be uh
with a local connection to unon
specifically that's just 25 people now I
appreciate the development is to 38
properties that is well over and above
that 25 figure and actually the seven
people that they identify through the
the local housing needs survey could be
included in that in that sort of figure
25 so there could be double counting
there anyway for me the the demand is
just not there it's not been proven as
it needs to be in in this exceptional
circumstance policy uh and I think
unfortunately the figures you know and I
think the report is very well written it
considers all of the the key issues but
I think the the figures from the housing
strategy team have just been taken at
face value and they've not been into
interrogated fully in the way that they
should be in my
opinion thank you Council
Elliot I think councelor D youve
actually answered most of the things I
were going to ask you there what I did
want to ask is um the 38 that are
proposed with the 100% affordable have
have you not just had um another another
scheme further down the road Nationwide
boat and list of Motors all all
affordable housing yeah I think another
speaker might be covering that point
already actually but yes so we've had I
think there's 48 properties that were
recently built at the former Boatyard
site which is literally just over the
border from onon um which is 100%
affordable and then another immediately
adjacent to that is currently being
built out of the minute which is 33
properties again 100% affordable and
there are other applications in
dronfield that that will be helping to
meet that need as well that have been
approved y
and the the safeguarded land that was
for the children for the school and so
on does this compromise the
entire
that all it just been squeezed I think I
think the as far as I'm aware and I've
had to recuse myself with my other role
as Cabinet member because of my
objection to the planning applications
I've not been as directly involved but
as far as I'm aware the land the total
availability of land will remain the
same it's just been shiting Ed around
the the development site so the so the
total land that's made available for the
school will be the same as it was but my
view would be it's a slightly worse
quality land because it's lower down the
site nearer the river more prone to
flooding and therefore um you know it's
less quality land poor quality land all
land in theh it is in the same ownership
yeah thank you councel this year another
question
so I I view policy lc3 as being a really
exceptional policy it's supposed to be
there you know to to Really and the five
tests in it and the fact that every
single one has to be met
um is is is really strong and it gives
that added protection to settlement
development limits the fear is that uh
an applicant for example in this in this
case can do do uh try to meet one of the
requirements Say by doing an upto-date
local housing needs survey not get the
answer that they want and then go to our
housing strategy team to get additional
information to try and make the case now
the exact policy wording doesn't say
they can do that it says it has to rely
on a local housing needs survey
um but they they've done that
nonetheless with this application and
the fear then for me is that everywhere
within the district that is desirable to
live that has a high demand you know
High number of applicants per properties
could see this happening in in those
communities that's not just the green
belt that's anywhere with a settlement
development limit which has land outside
of it you could have a developer coming
and saying well there's a really strong
case for affordable housing in this area
and therefore uh we should be uh you
know we should be allowing this
application to go ahead and the other
thing I'd say is and this is no
disrespect to housing strategy officers
they have a job to do and I fully fully
respect that but there is an inherent
Conflict for me because their whole role
their whole existence and role within
the council is about promoting and
encouraging the availability of
affordable housing so it's very rarely
going to be a case where they're going
to be asked for information and they're
going to say well no there isn't a a
demand for affordable housing because
that's not what their role is it's to
promote and encourage so for me I I just
I really fear that this case sets a
really worrying precedent if it's
approved I think that you know
settlement development limits should be
pretty saent we went through all the
pain of the local plan to get them in
place and if we end up with a situation
where we're sort of opening a can of
worms here with this one because I don't
think I I can see how lots of other
developers will be watching this and and
potentially um you know looking at other
sites that that are outside of
settlement development
limits okay thank you no more questions
uh like to seat again thank
you right we'll move on to the uh second
speaker on this uh uh an object Paul
Scott are you okay with the microphone
it's the little button to the right the
right hand side button that you need to
press
okay now just just press it and and then
press it again when you finished
speaking okay good afternoon I'd like to
talk about road safety and
biodiversity um I ask you to imagine
you're standing with your back to the
entrance to this proposed
development 60 MERS to your left you
have a blind Bend right hand bend over a
railway bridge between you and the bend
there a bus lay by the entrance to a
garden center to your right 40 MERS away
big Victorian School building built
quite close to the road road in front of
you you have a bike track crossing the
entrance and a pedestrian
pavement so sight lines for emerging
Vehicles very limited if there's a bus
standing at the bus stop even more
limited this is what will confront
Vehicles seeking to leave the site
they're joining the main drone field to
Chesterfield Road it's a busy road quite
narrow it has a 30 mph speed limit but
the unone community speed watch is
consistently recorded regular
significant speed in on this stretch of
road also vehicles coming from the
Chesterfield Direction after crossing
the Railway Bridge coming around the
bend may be immediately confronted with
vehicles standing in the middle of the
road waiting to turn right in front of
oncoming
traffic the developers say they expect
only 12 vehicle movements each way from
the site in the AM and PM
periods this looks very unrealistic when
you bear in mind that apart from an
infant and Junior school and a
hairdressers there are no facil
facilities within reasonable walking
distance of this site the nearest
facilities are 2 miles
away it is therefore very likely the
journeys from this site will be by car
there is a bus service outside but every
half hour and the buses take securest
routes to serve housing
Estates uh and they're not quick so most
Journeys from this site will have to be
taken by
car bearing this in mind the allowance
of 1.3 car parking spaces per household
does not look nearly enough each house
will probably have an average of two
vehicles and this still does not make
any allowance for visiting Vehicles if
this results in parking over spill onto
the main road this is going to make it
even more
congested bearing in mind traffic coming
and going from this site with the
restricted
views the possibility of parked cars on
the road a bus stop School pickup
traffic this is going to become a very
congested and is a very dangerous piece
of road 30 seconds remain thank you on
the subject of biodiversity people might
think this is just a field and it
doesn't matter a recent report shows the
UK to be the most depleted of 14 EUR um
diversity depleted of 14 European
countries if this field disappears along
with the ones that are going to built on
in dronfield then with that bit more
nature
depleted another bit of England's green
and present land and Northeast darvish's
semi- rural car to gone
forever so in the interest of road
safety and
biodiversity I ask you to vote against
this plan please thank you do any any
have
questions
speaker thank you chair um just to pick
up on um excuse me I got frog in my
throat on your community speed watch
data do you have the kind of proportions
of how many vehicles are speeding
percentage wise along that
road I don't have any any actual figures
but but uh I I believe from councilor
Dale uh that um the the are it it has
one of the highest incidences of
speeding of any Road in the area that's
been surveyed and and and consistent
speeding and some significant speed
thank
you any more questions um right if you'd
like to retake your seat please thank
you uh right the next speaker is uh Ian
Wright
objector yeah if you'd like to uh press
the right hand button when you're ready
thank you thank you I'm a 66y old
lifelong onon resident I appeal to the
planning committee to reject the
application on elements of policy lc3
section D which states affordable houses
quote should have a close association
with builtup parts of the settlement and
in keeping with the form size and
character of the settlement and local
landscape setting this is clearly not
the case as pointed out by the planning
policy manager quote the immediate
surroundings of the site are
characterized by the stone school
building and low density detached
dwellings set with ins sizable private
govern Gardens arranged in linear form
fronting the highway end quote again in
the words of the planning policy manager
the proposed scheme consists of a dense
cluster of Terrace blocks offset at an
angle from the highway therefore totally
out of character with the immediate
surroundings furthermore the South
Yorkshire Housing Association website
States in its opening paragraph about
the proposal this design has been
inspired by local miners cottages
I would say any comparison of The
Proposal with the minus Cottages in St
John's Road is a gross
misrepresentation there is no
resemblance to this historic development
which is a linear settlement dating back
to the Victorian era part of our village
history and our co- mining
Heritage these Cottages are almost half
a mile away from The Proposal casting
serious doubt over the degree to which
this is in keeping with the form size
and character
the claim the miners Cottages are the
inspiration behind the development
should be dismissed the plan is at best
to poor imitation more suited to an
urban city site the proposed Banks of
teres will bear no resemblance to
existing settlements and in essence will
be an isolated Enclave between two
existing settlements with no link to
either regarding being in keeping with a
local landscape the plan does not
satisfy this either the renowned view
across the Valley from the East side
side of onon Parish from hundall aeno
sum and cran is greatly admired by
residents and by many Ramblers and
walking associations who look across
this beautiful landscape this urbanlike
Bank of terraces will therefore
certainly not be in keeping with the
local landscape as required by policy
lc3 criteria D again I reference South
yorshire Housing associations own survey
which states subject to becoming
available and having local support I
stress local support these new homes
could be developed on a ro exception
site there is no local support from
either residents or the parish council
the voice of our residents and that our
elected representatives should be heard
in determining the future of our much
Village if a genuine consultative
approach is to be recognized I strongly
urge the planning committee to reject
the proposal not just to plead from the
heart but based on the grounds that
there is no demonstrable desire or need
particular on green belt and as many's
requirements under policy lc3 are not
met thank you very much uh thank you you
just remain seated uh yes Council
Foster
yes
yes no I can't simple answer no
lost
right right if you'd like to retake your
seats thank you very
much uh the next speaker on this um is
another objector Jonathan
aldroid is this is this microphone
microphone is on yeah so I'll switch
mine off and the camera should switch to
you okay great stuff thank you for
hearing my objection today it is my
strong strong feeling that the number
and scale of ongoing house building
projects in the immediate area satisfy
any reasonable assessment of the local
need for affordable homes these building
projects constitute from a practical
perspective alternative settlements that
contribute strongly to local housing
needs this removes any real
justification in my view for building on
a piece of green belt land that is so
visible from the surrounding Countryside
and so close to the habitats and
ecologies associated with ramsha Woods
if I can Briefly summarize these nearby
sites there's the Gladis bookon site
which is approved for 27 housers 30% of
these being affordable so that's eight
affordable homes there's the boat yard
site Which is less than a mile away and
comprises 48 properties all of which are
affordable the Boatyard site is finished
now but its construction predates the
housing needs survey so it should be
considered to be contributing to the
community's housing needs in my
opinion um thirdly the site neighboring
the Boatyard is for 33 houses it isn't
completely clear to me what proportion
of these are going to be affordable um
but the bare minimum would be 10% and
the application seems to imply that the
whole site of 33 in fact going to be
affordable um and lastly there is the
chestfield roadside which is going
through planning at the moment it too is
within a mile of unen and would provide
135 homes 30% of these would be
affordable so there's another 40 so in
total we're probably looking at
something like 243 homes of which
between 96 and 129 are affordable and
all of these are in sten's immediate
area one of the things that strikes me
most is that setting the context of the
area's history the next three four or
five years of house building activity
will occur within the blinking of an eye
to me that makes the green belt
regulation and the way that we apply it
all the more crucial it's during these
periods of change that our Countryside
is at its most vulnerable as Alex points
out there is no proven local need for
this housing as per lc3a seconds remain
and I hopefully highlight that uh the
community is already accommodating
substantial amounts of affordable
housing as per
lc3b in the absence of these criteria
being met and D as well there is no
actual basis for building on the green
belt in the first place I ask the
committee to reject the application
thank you Mr Al anybody got any
questions councel
Foster
yes well they're in onon green and um
that's you know feel feels very much
like our community and in terms of the
people who uh especially the people who
use the woods who walk in the
surrounding area who go to the same pubs
these are the same people um so yes
these this is part of our community and
despite the fact it being slightly over
the Border um this surely is from a
practical perspective meeting housing
needs thank you Mr any further questions
no if you'd like to retake your seat
thank you very
much uh the last speaker on on this
application is CLA Bond the
agent thank you CL are you
ready should have coughed before I
switched the mic on my name is CLA Bond
and I'm an architect at Sarah
Wigglesworth Architects we are experts
in housing design and specialists in
sustainability we were commissioned by
South Yorkshire Housing Association to
design the new homes at the unstone main
road site following consideration of all
relevant planing planning policies and
provision of additional material to
satisfy policy specific concerns our
proposal has received Universal support
from statutory planning consules with
conditions we can meet in particular we
have received recognition that our prop
osal provides high quality sustainable
housing which is well related to its
surroundings and sits alongside
significant trees landscaping and
biodiversity net gains all of which has
been designed to enhance the well-being
and promote a healthy lifestyle for the
neighborhood residents and local
ecology we have worked closely with
South Yorkshire Housing Association
Civic engineers nedc and DCC highways to
respond to both highways and local
resident comments as a result result we
have developed a safe coherent and
compliant Highway strategy using sound
technical evidence included within this
application officers consider based on
the advice received from the statutory
consult te that the proposed development
would not lead to demonstrable harm to
highway safety along main road or The
Wider Highway
Network we have also worked closely with
South Yorkshire Housing Association and
any DDC housing to assess the real need
for affordable housing in unstone
addition data from the council's housing
register demonstrated that there were
259 bids for only seven existing Council
properties in the period of 2021 to 22
there were also over 500 applicants with
a registered local connection to this
Ward subsequently from an any DDC
strategic housing perspective there is
sound evidence to suggest that there is
a high demand for afford affordable
housing in this area in addition due to
a full compliance with the criteria of
planning policy lc3 The Proposal is
considered by officers to to not be
inappropriate development in the green
belt to summarize we are proposing a
sensitive housing and Landscape scape
scheme for this site delivering
affordable and accessible homes where
there is a solid proven need and without
a negative impact on highways we are
delighted to have received support from
the planning officer and planning
consules who have recognized our green
Ambitions and the high quality
contribution that this development will
offer to unstone and the surrounding
area thank you uh thank you do have any
questions C
[Music]
ellot I think it's go you've not gone to
people in order it's it brings us up in
order Heather was first and I was second
and
Pete oh you can't have your own way
every time
DAV would you like to go before
me chair you make a decision
on thank you
chair
sorry oh gentlemen to the last so uh
when I when I read when I you say
experts in housing design and so on but
one of the objectives says that you've
not looked at the old Cobo style houses
and taking into account their history
with the with that coal and Mining area
I just want your comments on that please
yeah thank you for your question um we
spent a lot of time sort of in anston
Village going and speaking to Residents
that were living in the old coal mining
Cottages um and that was sort of what
drove I guess us to this ultimate design
proposal um they were incredibly
positive about that housing typology
about the sort of
um the the fact that the fronts and the
backs of the houses you couldn't
necessarily always tell which was the
front which was the back they had low
Garden walls long front Gardens long
back Gardens there was lots of
interaction with neighbors it felt like
a very close-knit Community um and it
was through our consultation with them
and the Really positive feedback that we
received from them about that particular
historic housing typology I guess
married with a lot of sort of historic
Research into the area in that
particular typology which is included
within the full planning application
that's ultimately what led us to um
reach the design that we that we
submitted thank you thank
you thank
you again uh thank you I'm really
confused now I was going to ask you
about gaban wall um whether you didn't
whether you thought as an architect a 4
meter gabian wall in open Countryside I
find that rather Urban rather than rural
that was my one question and also I'm
really confused now because you just
mentioned long front and back Gardens in
the miners Cottages these are exactly
the opposite so I'm a bit confused now
okay I'll start with the gabrian walls
so I guess the
the the sort of the cons key
consideration with this site as well is
making sure that we've got increased
biodiversity it's been referenced that
you know we need to make sure that we're
um we're celebrating existing
biodiversity in our Countryside and the
the great thing about the gabian baskets
is that they're able to provide us with
a um a framework for Greening so
ultimately that will read as sort of a
green wall I guess where we'll be able
to add to the biodiversity within the
the development as opposed to a kind of
very large stone wall which actually
wouldn't feel very appropriate for the
countryside either um so that's sort of
why we reached the conclusion that we
did with the the gaban wall and then
what was your second question sorry oh
it's about the fr the long Gardens
wasn't it yes so I guess what we've
tried to do is we've still made sure
that our front and uh rear Gardens are
pretty equal in size so they all exceed
the um immunity requirements that are
set out by the council for private
immunity and they follow those design
principles of having the kind of low um
front front sort of garden fences so
you've got the opportunity for
interaction with your neighbors when
you're sort of arriving coming home um
leaving have to do the school run or
whatever um and then in addition to that
we've sort of provided the uh sort of
public realm space as well which won't
just be for the residents in the new
development that will be for all of
unstone residents to enjoy um which is
sort of providing additional um Green
Space in that area as
well thank you and Council anop thanks
chair just excuse me because I
screenshotted this earlier to so I got
the exact reference but I'm wondering
how you actually Define the sound demand
for housing because in the
documentation um it is actually quite
speculatively it says this clearly shows
that the actual housing needs of
residents in the parish
could be significantly higher than the
survey presents so I would say that's
anything buts out I think there's been
some phrasing in in relation to specific
pieces of evidence I think there's been
some of the evidence which has been that
sort of particular terminology has been
referenced and then I think there's been
other parts of the evidence which
counselors have said they feel is um is
perhaps more robust and more sound um
but I I think we can kind of all use our
common sense that we're in a housing
crisis and you know those figures sort
of speak for themselves in terms of the
the need for housing
in well with respect it doesn't though
does it because we're building in Green
Belt so unlike a normal one where we
actually have to go on balance of
probabilities and we have to have a good
excuse for rejecting something the
opposite is true here it's got criteria
it needs to tick and the criteria for
this is proven need well this need is
speculative because we're pulling
numbers from all over the place and
that's why I'm asking you again to
justify how you're saying that it's
sound because it it just isn't in my
eyes CLA can you can sorry can you just
turn your microphone back on yes of
course sorry do you have the specific
piece of the full quote from the
documentation that you've
screenshotted yeah it's in yeah I can
read you the whole thing in
context um with the preceding paragraph
as well I mean it is quite clear there
when I get it
up it says in the case of the unstone
survey 836 questionnaires were posted to
the residents and 118 returned giving a
response rate of
14% a need was found for seven
affordable or social rented homes and
one open market home this clearly shows
that the actual housing need of
residents in the parish could be
significantly higher than the survey
presents and a much wider range of
property types could be required
so everything is could be yeah there's
no actual sound basis at all it's
speculative so that I think was based on
the kind of the the historic housing
survey need survey which had been done
um and I think the speculation there is
I agree sort of about whether the the
sort of the fact that certain um
responses weren't received whether that
equals housing need or not I think the
additional uh data that has been
provided by the council is sound you
know that's the stuff which is um is
proven to um and identify that there is
a need for affordable housing in this
area I think the speculation perhaps was
what was said to us as well which is why
then that additional data was was
provided um to ensure that you're right
it was robust and we are confident that
we are compliant with
lc3 thank you councel
Foster
only
satisf
I guess that we the the whole process of
this plan is a very complicated site as
as we all know this whole planning
process has been very collaborative with
nedc with all of the um con uh statutory
consules and I think that uh part of
that has been you know the way that one
would with other policies as well um
ensuring that the planning officer has
all the and the statutary consules have
all the information that they need to
make a sound
recommendation um and it was discussed
in that collaboration and with the
strategic housing officer that actually
for various reasons um which were all
included in the additional report that
s um sent across to
NDC but that housing need survey just
wasn't truly reflective and therefore
additional information in this scenario
was
needed um and it was through that
collaborative conversation with nedc
that um it was agreed that the
additional information um would would be
needed in this
scenario is is it quick point is it
quick
question right
okay
the
my view would be in this area of
UN
yes
yes well but they could be from Mone the
way that you're saying they could not be
from
unone
do you sorry do you want me to respond
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I guess the
the reality of it is is that we have
been presented with this data um we feel
alongside the plan is that that data is
sound it provides you with proven need
for affordable housing in this area in
the area of unstone um and that would be
my my conclusion I
guess no further questions I don't think
uh if you'd like to take your seat again
thank you thank
you uh right colleagues we will now move
on move on to questions to officers as
always I would like to keep this part of
our proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any points you are not
sure of once we have done this we can
then have our discussion about the
application based on all that we have
heard and
read so got any questions for officers
councel
an actually
councilor counc an's trying to steal my
wonder what's his game today
Cel thank you chair um question really
is to Phil and Adrien um we we've heard
mention about the gabian
walls when I look down that road and
drive down that road as I do day after
day the the walls down past the school
and up past the school over the over the
bridge the Railway Bridge are all in
stone so why why is there a conflict why
can't we have St stone walls that that
border this
site cuz I had mentioned that you know
the gaban will find and an all in
keeping well not to me they're
not there're an engineering solution
that provides biodiversity so that
they'll in effect be a green wall so it
will provide a more soft um design
approach than say the stone which would
be more harsh so over time they will
they will have planting grin up and they
provide a pleasant uh biodiversity um
and in conjunction with the with the
open space that's provided it should
provide a more Greener biodiverse um
center of the
side thanks Phil I mean I think the
stone walls you know the the stone built
walls would do the same thing and and
look more aesthetic to me but thank you
for the
answer councel thanks chair um question
is quite simple to be truthful in all
the years I've been on here we've been
told explicitly never to deviate from
the evidence that's in front of us
because that's the only thing that can
be backed up at appeal and today on page
47 we're being told to ignore the
evidence that's in front of us and take
whatever figures are collated Here There
and
Everywhere uh to try and justify why
we're going up from this seven or even
potentially eight up to 38 so I'm asking
why we've got that inconsistently
inconsistency what we're told
historically and we're changing it to
for this
application just in terms of how we as
officers chair have come to the
conclusion that we have in terms of the
need which I think is the the number of
council Hancock's question the policy
lc3a as has been debated sets out that
there should be a provision of
affordable housing to meet a proven need
which is reported by an up-to-date local
housing needs survey and we've
approached that in terms of our officer
assessment further to the original
submission by the applicant we've sought
that additional information that members
have been talking to various speakers
about and the original information set
out was the the need for the seven units
in onon if you like so we ask the same
question that members are asking do this
submission shows a need for seven but
you're you're seeking to provide 38 and
we asked for clarification of how that
had been arrived at and therefore in
addition to the up toate local housing
needs survey which supports the seven we
saw that additional information which is
set out on page 47 which as officers we
believe is evidence to support the
additional numbers I.E the information
that we've received from colleagues and
Thomas is is here this afternoon and
maybe be able to help in in terms of
some of the detail perhaps but we've
used that to identify and support the
additional numbers the additional 31 if
you like so as officers we would say
we've used the evidence before us to
identify that there is a proven need and
that does in addition Provide support
for the 38 further to the seven that are
actually identified in the replies to
the to the survey that was undertaken
we've gone one step further than that to
try and I understand the proven need in
our in our eyes but with respect Adrian
the policy the criteria is actually
quite specific and says aen need which
is supported by an up-to-date local
housing needs survey that survey is
actually valid up until
2026 so pulling extra figures in isn't
compliant with the policy itself because
that limits itself to that local housing
needs
survey through you CHF if I may that
we're as officers we've we've sought to
read the policy as as we read it if you
like so they would provide affordable
housing which would meet approve a
need so from the information that we
have we believe there's approv need for
38 if not more from the information that
we have perhaps up to the 259 that have
bided for the seven homes in the parish
and that is then supported by that
upto-date local housing need survey
which admittedly provides a lower number
but it Provide support for that larger
proven need so that's the way that we we
are reading the
policy hopefully that helps
chair
councilor um thank you chair I'll carry
on on the same point but I've got to tie
this down before I feel comfortable with
this policy because the policy uh to me
Mr kiram is quite clear uh lc38 we can't
change it and pretend it says something
else it doesn't it says a proven need
which is supported by an upto-date local
housing needs survey there is a proven
need the proven need is seven but we've
gone further a field and to be fair
that's not in the report How Far We've
gone we've only found that out from Dian
Parker recently the actual distance
we've had to go I'm surprised we haven't
gone further it's a shame we didn't go
into Chesterfield but we've gone further
and further and further until we've got
the figures we wanted we've gone as far
as like I said earlier appol hundle
eckington renishaw some of these players
these outlin Villages like dronfield and
uh
hundle and Ridgeway Ridgeway you know
that there's some very desirable places
where people want to live it's no wonder
if you go that far and go to those areas
you actually find those figures that you
need so the proven need uh isn't for
that area the only proven need for this
area is the one that we've heard from um
from the lady who represents the de the
developers and that's for the seven for
the actual area so for this specific
area it it's just that seven and no more
we can't extrapolate it there's no
mechanism within this policy to actually
do that what we've done is we've looked
elsewhere because we're not happy with
the answer so for me what I'm looking at
here is the housing on P bottom of page
39 uh the housing needs survey which was
carried out in 2021 which is what we're
actually relying on and that's all we
can rely on because that's PO said the
only thing had a disappoint
disappointing response rate so when it
says disappointed what we really mean
here is we didn't hear what we wanted to
hear so we've gone elsewhere so that's
my concern and so do you still feel
comfortable as an officer that that
lc3a we're compliant with it because to
me and I think others here it doesn't
look like that at all it's not a proven
need it's not for that area we've had to
go elsewhere and the only housing needs
survey which is there which we do
actually need and relying on it gives us
concrete information it's there and it's
it's it's relevant and it gives us seven
and and and as it happens just as a last
point there was a question there chair
there was what is the question the
question was does he feel confident in
that and we're looking at seven we've
also got information can you that point
how you do you feel comfortable with
that that seven yes chair for for the
information and the the reasons that I
gave earlier um indeed in some appeals
that that admittedly dated now um
inspectors have taken a view that the
need could be District One it could be
even sub Regional wide chair so um
comfortable in terms of the way that
we've interpreted the policy and the
advice that we're given
yes thank you any further questions kler
Elliot thanks chair Adan I guess my
question is going to be comfortable with
something as well and and mine it
relates to all the self-same things
about appearing with the number of seven
but mine is a bit more on the ss9 cuz
for me it's development in the
countryside it's green belt it's outside
the settlement development limit and I
know we don't normally um talk about
other planning um sites but we threw one
out that was outside the settlement
development limit on a Green Field in
Kao last week which they tried to do as
100% um affordable and we knew that
would potentially come back and bite us
because they'll turn around and go oh we
can't develop it because we can't afford
to do all of it 100% now now so it's
like a loophole to get around it if
these say seven as far as I'm concerned
it's seven and that that you can make up
the figures from drumf and ekon and
killer Marsh and everywhere in between
but if it's seven it's seven and it's
outside the settlement development and
it's on Green Field I don't know where
we're going with this I know where I'm
going with it but I don't know where
everybody else is
going so are you comfortable with that
Adrian I can only r chair what I said a
few minutes ago members will need to
take a view this afternoon whether they
agree with the officer interpretation or
not if you don't believe that the policy
lc3 and therefore your policy ss10 a
green belt is satisfied then your
conclusion would be that it would be
inappropriate development in the green
belt and then you would follow on from
that just in terms of the policy that
Council Elli referred to ss9 that's a
different different matter because the
green belt policy is whether development
is appropriate or inappropriate or not
inappropriate so so that that's uh
that's an issue that that members have
debated with speakers and and you
probably debate amongst yourselves in a
few minutes and you'll need to conclude
on the Green Belt issue the impact on
the character of the area is a different
matter and if your concern is regarding
design or layout or any of those other
issues then that would would be a
different argument that you would need
to come to a conclusion on so acceptable
or not in Green Belt terms so
inappropriate or not inappropriate is
one one issue which you you'll come to a
conclusion on from the evidence the
information that you've got impact on
the countryside would be another issue
as would highway safety or ecology or
all those those other matters hopefully
that answers the question
wasit right thank you no further
questions for
officers no good right uh thank you uh
for that Adrian uh this leads us to the
final part of the process our discussion
about what we have heard what we think
and what we want to decide but before we
go any further I would like the Clark to
remind us about
motions right thank you
chair please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
aot vote is
taken if an amendment to a motion is
moved and seconded then that Amendment
will be voted on
first if a motion is to be moved which
goes against the officer's
recommendations then the member who has
moved the motion must give the reasons
for doing
so the reason for moving a motion
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or in other words
it is not passed that doesn't mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved rather you will need to take a
positive decision through a further
Motion in favor of the recommendations
or a different course of action this
will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote thank you
chair thank you
Alan uh right I would like to open the
floor for
debate then go for
it canel Foster uh thank you uh I've
spoken about lc3 but I've got a second
issue which is a real con concern and
that's a national planning framework uh
it's mentioned briefly on page 53 when
it comes to design layout but not when
it comes to with regards to the green
bell apart from on page
46 if we're all following this debate
I'll give you a chance to find it on
page 46 towards the bottom it says on
7.3 inappropriate development is by
definition harmful to the green belt and
should not be approved except in very
special circumstances as those uh some
people will know here that's actually
paragraph 147 if at any time uh I need
to be corrected by officers chair please
let them uh jump in and I'm happy to
discuss this yeah so that's paragraph
147 of the planning framework uh so it's
clearly relevant when we look at what's
actually allowed in the green belt we
have to move to paragraph
149 and the bit that's relevant is
f of 149 a local planning Authority
should regard the construction of new
buildings as inappropriate in the green
belt and this then you're given
exceptions and F limited affordable
housing for local community needs on
policies set out in the development plan
so limited affordable housing for local
community needs now at length uh I've
gone on and discussed the local
community needs and said that this is
not local the needs aren't local we've
heard from the the developer that the
that the they thought those Figures were
local and the full 500 could have been
in onon but they're clearly not they go
much wider as we know so the local we'
covered already what I want to touch on
is the actual definition of limited and
I'd happily hear from Mr Mr Kirk any
other planning officer on this when we
talk about
limited uh so 38 is definitely not
limited when it comes to building now in
the planning framework
itself there is no guidance on this and
to look for it and thanks thanks for
that no Mr kiram to to to look further
what you have to do is you have to look
at case law and a recent case explains
this and it's Hillcrest abson Road
puckle church and this was with this was
uh for exactly the same sort of thing it
was 15 affordable properties in the
green belt and it was dismissed on
appeal and I'll pass these two uh
documents across this is for Mr Kirk and
planning officers to look
at and the key thing here it's not to
look at the full case at all yeah it's
purely to look at where I found what
limited meant when it came to paragraph
149f So it explains there pass them all
on under 13 what limited actually refers
to so the appellant considers that this
is the report of the the um the planning
inspectorate which actually supported uh
the council in turning down this
application the appellant considers that
the number of residential units proposed
is limited numerically compared to some
of the much larger housing allocations
in the council's development plan their
local plan whilst the number of units
proposed might be limited when taken as
a proportion of some of these larger
sites the term limited and this is the
important part in so far as it relates
to the framework must be understood in
context with the fun fental aim of green
belt policy to prevent Urban spoil and
keeping the land permanently open so
when you look at the the green belt
balance and conclusion it goes into uh
on uh goes further on into it into 31
actually supporting the original
council's decision in turning this down
when it when it relates
to paragraph
149f which I'll go over again which says
limited affordable housing for local
community needs we've covered local and
now have covered limited this is not
limited at all this was for 15 hour and
15 hour in case law is not said to be
limited when it comes to development on
Green Belt that's
15 here we're looking at 38 now 38 is
certainly not limited at all now there's
other cases you can find as well if you
look on the planning portal and you can
find out the definition of what limited
is it's not in the the planning
framework but it is there and we've been
told time and time again this is what we
rely on when it comes to making
decisions and placing uh putting things
under material consideration and weight
in this
committee so for me 38 is not limited
and that recent case um explains that so
other comments Alik while while I'm
still speaking s coming back later on uh
it's a major development in an
unsustainable location key it's not in
our local plan it's speculative
development from South Yorkshire housing
from South Yorkshire and it clearly goes
against our policies lc3 and now I've
proven there and i' happily he from uh
from uh from officers that it goes
against the planning framework as well
especially 149f and I'd ask other
councilors here to look that up on the
phones or whatever uh means you've got
here so these are strong material
planning considerations and they must be
given weight here so that's where our
judgment lies and that's why we must
reject this here this green belt land it
belongs to the people of unon it must be
protected for them and their families
and not giving over to South Yorkshire
housing so at the appropriate time I
will be putting
forward uh not now I've had that lesson
already I will be putting forward a
motion to reject this application thank
you for that
chair right at least we're clear where
you stand councel fster um right anybody
else got anything to add to this
debate thank you chair yeah I'm actually
going to agree with most of what Mark
said here I mean the key thing is when
you've got something in the green belt
you've got your definition it must take
all the boxes on those criteria if
you're not if you're wanting to proceed
it's not open to debate it is black and
white it falls down at the first hurdle
so actually there's no point in even
going to B CDE e and whatever else it
just doesn't meet criteria on a so I
can't see that we can support it if it
was for seven it would be hard to turn
down on that but the fact that it's it's
for way more than it in that um local
housing lead survey I just don't see how
we can take it any
further canel
it thank you uh anybody else got
anything to
add right uh thanks colleagues having
heard and read everything um today and
the officer recommendation before us
what is a view of committee on the
application I am now opening the floor
to
motions councelor
Foster thank you chair as I said earlier
I will be putting a motion forward to
reject this uh I'll give the um I give
our CL uh to um to write this down it
will be that the policy has not being
met
lc3a that there is no proven need as
we've
discussed um and also on the grounds
that it does not cover the national
planning framework paragraph 149f which
it must do and it's not something that's
actually that's been mentioned in the
report so on both of those and um
and could ask do the chair um no I'll
leave that one but yeah thank you
chair thank you we got a second to
council thank you chair uh for all the
very same reasons as councilor Foster I
will second his motion I'd also like to
add ss1 for sustainable development
being as in that locality the pup shot
the post offic is shot etc etc uh and
mine was the the ss9
ss10
thank you thank you
chair chair through you just just ask
some clarification on on those matters I
I understand um um fully councel
Foster's point I understand that in
terms of the um develop being
inappropriate contrary to policy in
effect lc3 stroke ss10 I'm I'm less sure
about Council Elliot's issues chair and
whether the the committee are will be
voting on the issue of the development
being genuinely
unsustainable and I just ask you to i'
just like to understand that in a bit
more detail as to why it's unsustainable
in what terms because there's a there's
a bus route that goes past the the end
of the road the cycle Lanes Etc and then
on the other issue um we had some
discussion about ss9 and whether that
also forms part of the concerns of of
the committee in terms of what what is
the concern about ss9 so it's Ju Just
that clarification chair just um so that
as officers we can interpret exactly the
wishes of the the planning committee
should you vote for for that
motion thank you ad so who's going to
Clarity on those as count or
you then Council Foster yeah I'm a bit
concerned about including that in my
original um original proposal because
what I put forth the lc3 and the
national plan planning framewor is quite
clear and it gives other people here to
vote for that and it gives so they know
exactly where we are uh if if that's
okay because what what we haven't done
we we haven't debated those points and
other people aren't aware of those and
it might stop people voting against this
because what we' we've discussed at lent
The Proven need lc3 and now the planning
framework uh that it doesn't fulfill
those so I think it's clear to people
they know exactly where they
are
I'm happy with the
two can we if we can we do with the
thank you
chair apologize chair just so I can be
absolutely clear you want would members
should you vote for the motion want
reference to policy ss9 staying in the
the um reasons or reason for refusal no
LC
lc3 yeah
ss10 understand that and the
mppf
yeah in terms of paragraph 149 f it
follows then through into the local plan
so it's very similar in in terms of that
detail it's then carried through into
policy ss10
lc3 so we we we'd include that in as as
part of any Catal as as we do generally
speaking because your local plan to
generally be in accordance with the the
mppf anyway so we we add that words that
those those words
in right members we have a motion chair
can we just be absolutely clear on this
then so it's that's what I was going to
do I was just going to ask you to to
clarify that that we were clear what we
were voed on yeah thank you Al thank you
sh so basically um as I understand it it
is to reject um the application on the
grounds that it's uh not in line with
policy
lc3a uh LCT LC sorry ss10 on the ground
that there's no proven um need for it uh
it doesn't meet also the provisions of
npf 149 given that it is outside the
green belt or in the green belt and
outside the development limit 149 149 F
to apologize is that the essence of it
members and and we frame that chair into
terms of inappropriate development as as
Council fost has discussed and
debated okay everyone clear right we'll
move to the uh
vote right has everybody uh voted
everyone uh can see it on the screen can
uh just clarify that you're correct with
that
vote yeah right fig right the full
figures we have uh five for the motion
and six against so the motion has
fallen uh right thanks colleagues the uh
motion has been Reed
Ed um have we got any
uh anybody else who wants
to comment on this thank you uh thank
you chair um I propose that we accept uh
officer
recommendations and I move that
motion I could give you some grounds
actually um
I believe that we've been given the
correct and relevant
information I've looked at the local
plan and
I don't agree with your representation
of it or your understanding of
itair I'm not asking for whether you
agree I'm asking for What policies
through with your motion so I know what
to
okay
uh yeah we well I believe that the
criteria of lc3 has been met rather than
not not met so on that provision I would
like to move the
motion thank you do have a
second second
chair thank you Council jtim right we'll
move to the
vote
thank you that's uh is everyone clear
that they want to vote no changes right
um that um that motion is
carried thank
you six for and three against one
abstention
uh yeah if uh people who attended for
that particular
application you welcome to go you can
stay if you would
like thank
you
right uh thank you colleagues um we'll
now move on to the second application
n2300
373 killer Mar uh revised proposal for
change of use from retail to ret retail
shop to a mro pub I'll not read out the
rest of uh uh the explanation uh on the
application uh I'm going to ask the
planning officer to tell us about any
late comments and to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the site I'll allow the
officers to complete the presentation
consequently members unless you have a
point of order that you feel cannot wait
could you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end
so okay
on so I believe we've got kry Alan is
going to speak for this and give us this
presentation so we'll just let Cel anok
return to his
seat thank
you
thank you chair um I'd just like to
refer members to the late
representations for this item that was
sent out to yesterday afternoon um this
application seeks full planning
permission to change the use of a retail
shop to a micrb including a two-story
side extension the application is a
resubmission of a previously refused
application the site is located within
the settled development limit of Kil
Marsh the main planning considerations
here are the design impact of the
extension impact of the use of of the
use on neighboring properties highway
safety and land stability no sty
consules have identified any technical
reasons as to why this application
should be
refused um this scenari photo showing
the applications are highlighted in
yellow and the surrounding area access
is taken off Cherry Tree Drive which is
included in the yellow shaded
area
uh this is just a more zoomed in um
photo of the application site the
application site forms um is a semi-
detached property uh the adjoining
property is a hot food takeaway at
ground floor with the flat above um to
the east of the application site is the
former B and Badger Public House which
has been converted into Flats to the
south of the application site is a row
of four Terrace Residential Properties
and to the northwest of the application
site or Residential Properties on Fox
croft
drive uh this is the site location plan
which shows the extent of the
application sou Outland in red including
the access off Cherry Tree Drive the
extension is shown on the western side
of the existing
property um this slide shows the
existing elevations and floor plans um
of the whole
building and this slide shows the
proposed elevations and the ground floor
plan of the building The Proposal
includes extending the building to the
west by 6.5 M with a depth of 10 m The
Ridge and Eaves height match the
existing
building uh this is the proposed ground
floor and first floor
plans and then just some photos um this
is taken from from Cherry Tree Drive
looking towards the application
site um the the properties on the left
hand side of the four Terrace property
for residential terrorist properties um
and then the former B and Badger uh
Public House which has now been
converted to Flats can be seen on the
right and then just beyond the
application site you can see the roofs
um of the properties on foxcraft
Drive um this is a photo just shown
where the um the location of the
extension would
be um and there's a series of foot paths
that run um close by the site so the
next two photos are just taken from the
um from the foot
paths um so this is from the foot path
that runs adjacent to the properties on
Spruce Drive and foxcross drive looking
back towards the application
side and then this photo is at the rear
of the application site um so the
application site is on the left um and
to the right it's a boundary treatment
um with 40 48 and 50 foxc Drive officers
are of the view that proposal is
considered to be accept and an
acceptable form of development within
the settlement development limits of
kiler Marsh whilst there is potential
for noise and disturbance from the use
this can be reduced and controlled
through the imposition of planning
conditions and a licensing application
which is separate to the planning
process the proposals are considered to
be acceptable in terms of its design
visual impact impact on neighboring
properties cor risk and Highway Safety
accordingly officers are recommending
that the application be
approved um just a point um to note one
of the conditions condition six refers
to um sections 5 .2 and 5.3 of the noise
impact assessment um this should read as
6.2 and 6.3 so if members are minded to
go with the recommendation I would
advise that we um correct this in the
wording of the condition thank you
chair uh thank
you uh right colleagues we have uh one
speaker on the application uh this is
John gr the agent and he will be joining
us by teams he will have three minutes
to get over his point points and we'll
be informed when 30 seconds
remain uh you can ask him uh to clarify
any matters that have been raised but
remember your questions should only
relate to the points which have already
been made so I'm going to hand you over
to
uh the uh Team
section
Mr you've got three minutes thank
you I think you're muted at the
moment
Mr gr can you hear us
okay uh you you muted I'm afraid so we
can't hear you in the
chamber
microphone
usually uh apparently the microphone is
not symbol is normally at the top of the
screen I have that but uh yeah we can
hear you now so uh yeah you've got three
minutes excellent thank you okay thank
you um thank you chairman uh John Groves
I'm a chartered Town planner and I
represent the uh applicant in in this
case um thanks for the opportunity to
address members uh we're very
appreciative of the well-considered
officer report on this application which
I hope has been um brought forward with
a recommendation of approval because of
the responses that we've been able to
provide when the case officer has raised
issues and had questions about
particular details of the application
and through that process of negotiation
we feel that uh we now have a scheme
which is appropriate to members uh for
members to consider and and and approve
uh you've already noted that the
application has been or a similar
application was refused before that was
useful in many respects in that it
highlighted issues which needed to be
addressed and we have addressed each of
those and and I think satisfactory in
terms again of the officer
report um The Proposal is now now much
smaller than it was previously and takes
up uh less space less space allocated to
the to the posed use um we consider that
this is um hopefully tending to be a
community facility that will serve the
immediate locality so it's clearly in
the applicant's interest to make sure
that it sits comfortably within that
community and doesn't cause any issues
or problems uh we we believe that other
similar operations as one in in mosa
craftwork operates on that basis and
provides such a facility for people to
come in and meet have a cup of coffee or
a beer or whatever and and communicate
much different to a traditional Pub
Enterprise
um it's it's notable that um the
officers have asked for detailed noise
assessments and we provided those and
that leads to the level of control over
the propos proposed use which is
suggested particularly in condition 8
before you which talks about hours of
operation um an interesting issue in
that respect is obviously the building
is already a retail use um that's now
within Class E of the used classes order
and it could become a cafe without the
need for any further planning permission
at all it couldn't be extended the
extension needs Planning Commission but
the use could change without the need
for Planning Commission and we consider
on that basis alone there's
justification for allowing the
development and allowing a proposal
which you have full control over in
terms of hours of operation and and use
by virtual condition 8 thank you chair
that's all I have uh thank you Mr G
um right uh do any members have any
questions about the points which the
speaker has raised in his
presentation no thank you move on to uh
colleagues you you will now have the
opportunity to put questions to officers
about the
application nobody right no questions
for officers thank
you uh right this leads us to the final
part of the process our discussion about
what we have heard and what we think and
what we want to decide I would like to
open the floor for debate
Council
fer yeah my concern is around noise uh
especially this outdoor beer garden
there's talk of a uh it
being uh it being limited to 9:00 uh I
don't think we're um licensing is able
to put that uh that that measure on
where it could where it can be stopped
and that noise can be limited uh even up
to 9:00 9:00 I think uh you you've got a
quantity of people outside drinking uh
and socializing that's going to uh
affect nearby residents uh for me it
doesn't meet sdc12
e it doesn't protect the amenity of
existing
occupies thank
you anybody else got anything to
contribute counc again yeah just a
question about who actually owns the
land that's the opposed beer garden
because I understand Northeast have been
mowing
it as far as I understand the the land
within the red line which is the
applicant application site um is in the
ownership of the the applicant um they
have served notice on a number of people
um as part of their application but my
understanding is that is um in relation
to the shared um shared car parking at
the front and at the side um they
haven't served notice on anybody at the
for the land at the rear so my
understanding that it is in the land of
sorry in the ownership of the
applicant counc
an thanks chair I think my only
potential concern on this is is parking
which hopefully too many clients won't
be parking because they'll be walking
but uh obviously there's going to be
stuff there at various points so I think
that that that is a concern but overall
I think in terms of noise and opening
Nows I think the conditions
actually actually cover and protect most
of the things so whil I've got a nle I
think I'll would be supported on
there thank you anybody else want to
have
anything uh right
uh having heard everything today and the
officer recommendation before us what is
the view of the committee on the
application I am now opening the floor
to
motion
I'm happy to go with off officer
recommendations Council
house
yeah right we we have a motion on the
floor for accepting officer
recommendations so if we can put that to
the vote
please
is everybody clear and happy with how
they
voted yeah okay right that motion has
carried nine for one abstention and one
against thank
you
uh right thank you colleagues uh we now
move on to the third application which
is
n23
00743 slfl drum
field um proposed single story side
extension uh I believe this is a a
reapplication uh from a previous
accepted uh proposal uh I'm going to ask
the planning officers to tell us about
any late comments and to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the side I will allow the offic
officers to complete the presentation
consequently members unless you have any
point of order that youth feel cannot
wait could you please reserve these or
any questions about the process until
the end so I'm now handing over to
kenle thank you chair um first of all I
need to refer you to the late reps
report for um which was published there
is a late representation from DCC but
this raises no new
issues um the application is
23743 propos single story side extension
and raising of existing roof
incorporating bellic's window
um at at 14 Trent Grove it consists of a
res revised scheme of previously
approved application
23158 um so it's important to note that
the principle of the additional stories
and extensions is established the
question is around the
appearance and the amenity particularly
bearing in mind it it relatively close
relationship to 25 d Road next
slide this slide shows the site context
the land levels slope upwards to the
north to the top of the picture and 25
Durant Road is to the right as you look
at
it um the properties share a common
boundary which can be seen at the edge
there the next
slide sorry Go Go pass that
one um this slide shows the opposed
against the previously approved
application the previously approved
being um on the left and on the right
the current planning application that
that shows the offshoot which had been
removed next
slide and this slide shows the
view um which is from d Road shows the
proposed against the previously approved
again the previously approved being in
GR the blue sh in The Proposal uh if
members note the measurements all in
millimeters showing that the ridge has
moved 869 mil to the north is 670 mil
higher and also the change in the window
to the
rear members should be aware that this
rep that the grve represents a fall back
position as it is a an improved
application and then the changes in
Ridge height should be noted along with
the position of the
window next slide this slide shows the
um a Sun Tracker uh it is dated for the
14th of October and the lines show sun
on that date including sunrise and
sunset shaded area is a track of the sun
throughout the
year and that is from the vantage point
of the closest windows on to 25 dur
drive next
slide this slide is taken um this photo
is taken from in front of the windows of
number 25 do drive it shows the
relationship showing the finish level of
the roof and the Ridge and also the
window to the
rear the next slide and this one is the
second one I'm going to show and this is
to the rear of 25 d d Road sorry this is
is an area that that it appears seems to
be the main private immunity area for
the residents
there that's it thank you that's the end
of
the
slides thank you for that
K all right colleagues we have two
speakers on the application the first
first of whom is uh Christopher Stacy an
objector he will have three minutes to
get over his points and will be informed
when he has 30 seconds remain you can
ask him to clarify any matters that have
been raised but remember your questions
should only relate to the points which
they have already
made right thank you very much thank you
Mr sty you got three minutes um I think
the main criteria for me is that this
doesn't meet uh it didn't initially meet
the requirements of the drum field plan
um which actually
States
uh a detailed report was undertaken
which provides strong evidence that the
need for smaller one and two bedroom
dwellings will grow significantly while
some of this need will be met created by
first time buyers more
significantly will be the growth of the
households of retirement age this
application actually reduces the stock
of such houses and replac it with much
more expensive for bedroom property I
appreciate that you've already passed
this but I live it's 27 road actually I
live this is the most effective property
and we never received a letter from the
planning department to allow us to
object in the first place and neither
did another adjoining property 206
homely Lane this new require this this
property has been built
um looks directly into my lounge the
window of the end of the property looks
directly into my lounge and it
overshadows I don't know about the DAT
in October but for certain times in
Spring and Autumn the sun actually goes
down an hour later an hour earlier sorry
behind this
property and it doesn't shine on my
property at all I have to tell turn my
lights on and the heating on earlier if
it's sunny uh because it doesn't get
that light and heat anymore and that is
for that will be in Spring and
Autumn the actual date of whatever it is
in October isn't actually relevant to
the rest of the
year um there is a property at the
back uh over the top of this Ridge that
um is two story as well but it's most
people can't see that property and the
Eastern end of this property overlooks
206 hom Lane you've only be able to
build that property to one story level
where it actually looks over 206 H Lane
and it has a blank wall at that end no
window because it overlooks it that's
it uh thank you do uh any members have
any
questions thank you
counciler thank you chair thank you for
that Mr stery uh you mentioned early
about your loss of privacy uh what my
concern is I've seen the property and
I've seen that uh that overlooking
window uh is it possible officers could
bring the uh that picture up on the on
the
screen the one with the the window
overlooking the
garden that's obviously taken from your
garden yeah Y and it's uh there now when
I've seen when I've seen that uh that
there as I stood and I know there'll be
a little bit of growth on that hedge
since I was there that uh photo looks
like it's taken with a very low camera
yeah it looks like it does that that
doesn't look reflective of me me at all
no actually I don't know if Ken took a
picture from inside the
property but the property uh is just to
the right the the actual Lounge window
is the to the right it isn't
representative as you see also that
hedge I've allowed it to grow a meter
high if you look at the Hedge on the
left hand side that's the normal height
of that hedge about 2 meters and I can
cut that quite easily the Hedge at the
bike I've tried to let grow because
obviously trying to retain some privacy
uh but I won't be able to cut that it'll
cost me I've had a quot cost me1 120
pound twice a year to have it cut if it
grows up sufficiently high but I think
it's I would prefer to have le left is
at 2 meters which is I consider a
reasonable
height yeah coun thank you chair what
I'm trying to get to the bottom of Mr
stac is if you stand at your Lounge
window that uh that uh window looks
directly into your Lounge from there and
I don't think other people can actually
see that there because shots taken from
down there I believe yeah I have got a
picture but I'm not allowed to show a
picture okay thank you thank you
chair thank you any else have any
questions right Mr sty you can retake
your
seat right the second speaker on this
application is uh Mr James Kemp uh the
applicant good afternoon thank you very
much you've got three minutes okay thank
you yeah I'm the applicant and the owner
of 14 Trent Grove I'd like to start by
assuring the committee that I have acted
in professional manner from the outset
and the aid with the planning officers
throughout
when I submitted the original
application in February I was
sympathetic to the street scene on Trent
Grove there are a mixture of two story
detached houses Dum Bungalows Bungalows
and a newly built Chalet
Bungalow upon receiving approval in
April I then obtained detailed tenders
please note that I didn't didn't
purchase the Bungalow until I received
approval it was at this point I was
advised to amend the proposals due to
the costs associated with the found
foundations this was approximately
25,000 because there's a 10 m drop um
between my property and homely Lane
after seeking further advice from a
structure engineer I agreed to reiterate
I Leed with the planning officer
throughout this amended
scheme the amended proposals essentially
remove the L footprint making the
footprint overall smaller than the
approved scheme all be albeit like the
planning officer has stated six
70 uh millim higher at the ridge but
almost a meter further north also more
importantly the window position is the
same height and moves nearly a meter
further north than the original approved
application although similar in design
to 16 Trent grow which is the new shalet
Bungalow with bedroom accom
accommodation in the roof space my
proposal is lower from ground to Eevees
level there is mention in the objection
that my uh proposal has an effect on the
properties of the re with regards
sunlight uh with looking at the sun Cal
again the sun sets before it even
reaches my house from early October
onwards that's also ignoring the fact
that my Bungalows orientation hasn't
changed let's not forget there's a
bungalow there in the first place and
the the near the Hedge at the back is
2.7 m is high between our
properties and finally I'd just like to
advise that my neighbors on Trent Grove
have been extremely supportive and
certainly not distressed by the
development thank
you uh thank you do we have any uh
questions for the speaker can just one
chair um the window that we've been
talking about looks directly into a
lounge what is is that a
bedroom it's not directly there's there
is an angle uh I think the angle is
about 70° it's not direct at all it is a
bedroom window so is there any way that
could be obscured or would that um if
that was necessary I'm
sure yeah thank you thanks
[Music]
J no more questions right want to
ret right
colleagues you now the opportunity to
put questions to our officers on the
application councelor
Foster thank you chair uh are we able
question to officers are we able to put
on a condition that that glass is
obscured chair if um members are
otherwise um comfortable with the
submission other than that issue then
yes if you believe that was necessary
you could put a condition on requiring
the window to be obscurely glazed you
could
require be on opening you have it
opening in a certain way or restricted
in opening if if you believe that was um
that was required to make an accept yes
you
could yeah coming back on that chair
yeah my concern much like councilor is
it is about the loss of privacy I'm not
sure uh about openers but certainly when
it comes to having Opa glass I think
that's a condition that that we could
consider
um I've got a question for that on
Adrian um where are we with policy on
whether that uh glass is suitable
whether it needs to be glazed in the
Frosted nature or whether it's far
enough away from the property to the
rear wher the policy with that yeah just
in terms of of the distance to the
property chair
the from the rear facade of the
applicant's property to the nearest
point on the most effective property I
think is the one just c f refer to the
nearest point of where the the wall is
at 90 Dees is um just under 21 MERS
which you would normally have facing
facing Windows the nearest point from
that rear facade where the window is to
the most impacted property is just from
my measurements is just an excess of 21
MERS which you would normally look for
but in this instance the distance from
the rear facade to the boundary is under
slightly under the 10.5 meters you would
normally look for so in terms of making
the development acceptable if you don't
believe in its current form without any
obscurity to the glazing you could put a
condition on requiring that window to
the rear to be obscurely glazed and just
in brief discussion with Ken probably
suggest if that was the issue that most
was of concern to members you might want
the right hand pain of that to only be
able to open hinged on the right hand
side when looking out so that the window
came in and didn't therefore allow
direct looking through the glass towards
the garden you'd look in a in a slightly
obscure way so that that would be my
suggestion if members are concerned
about that you do put a condition on
requiring um the glazing to be obscurely
finished and with that hinged on the
right well hinged on both sides if you
like so it didn't open out from the from
the top but was a policy framework are
we um is it is it meeting the
requirements for policy framework that's
if you believe that is um um required to
make the development tax have yes you
would be in your rights to to require
that as you would require that as a
condition I think to require both this
imposition and then retention
subsequently okay thank you
sorry Adrian I'm still not quite clear
on that one um as it currently stands is
this application uh currently fit to be
approved without the necessity for the
glazing and and the for mentioned
hinging or is it a necessity as it
currently stands to be GL frosted
over current my understanding is it
currently meets the
requirements mpf Etc
in in terms of the distances between
facing Windows it would the only issue
that it wouldn't meet your normal
requirement is in terms of the depth of
the garden from the window to the rear
boundary you would normally be looking
for 10.5 meters for that it's slightly
under that so because of that distance
to the
boundary the uh frosting of the glass
and the hinging of the window
essentially makes that more of a
necessity than it would was it not for
that factor
in our balance as officers we've not
sought to impose that condition right on
on balance yeah however if um the
concern amongst the planning committee
is that that is an issue in view of that
slight reduction what you would normally
require you could put that condition on
which would then mean that the the
impact would certainly view of officers
would be reduced to to an acceptable
level it's currently viewed by officers
that this meets the requirements on
balance
in order to be satisfactorily passed
this is this is an enhancing condition
not an necess necessitating one yes now
s to be corrected by by Ken here but
we've taken into account that because of
the existence of the existing hedge
yeah so that that's been in our
consideration extra objective for okay
so it's not required to as things
currently stand sorry and and as I say
just to emphasize our unbalance view is
is taken into account the the Hedge
we've heard discussion about retention
of that this afternoon so you would need
to take a view on that but that that's
our that's the way that we've balance it
his
offices Council Foster uh yeah thank you
chair yeah we've heard that the depth of
garden is something that can be solved
than that lack of privacy that can be
solved with that condition I'm more than
happy with that condition uh and
hopefully the uh the resident at 27 de
Road would be satisfied that that helped
uh keep his lounge and his garden more
private uh but we've also had offer from
the applicant that they would be happy
with that uh with with the opaque glass
so I'm minded to think that you know
it's something we should put on as a
condition and it will satisfy that depth
of God and loss of privacy thank you
chair thank you Council PST councel OT
thanks chair Marx just said exactly what
I was going to say the reason I brought
up the obscuring the glass is it may
plate both the objector and we've heard
from the applicant that he's quite happy
to do that because it privacy works both
ways you can see straight from the
lounge window into this new bedroom so
it it would it would benefit both
parties so I I'm saying i' be minded to
ask for it to be obscured or the
transoms or whatever the window openings
are to to assist
it thank you no questions for officers
got a question is a comment if you if
you wanted to you want to just bring it
up in debate yeah that's fine it's fall
to uh right uh thank you for that offic
say this ISS to the final part of the
process our discussion about what we
heard what we think and what we want to
decide I would now like to open the
floor for debate councel and
cook thanks chair yeah I mean just to
pick up on the comments that have been
going backwards and forwards obviously I
don't live in that area but I me and my
rear neighbor they're in a bungalow with
exactly the same sort of setup obviously
it predates current planning rules you
can see straight out of their upstairs
window into my kitchen and vice versa
and there's a hell of a lot more than 20
meters between us so I would be I think
for both parties um having obscured
glass and and restricting how the
windows open will be beneficial to both
of them I would support it on there and
yeah I know we're saying it meets these
distances in certain aspects but knowing
what it's like when I've probably got 40
meters between me and my re neighbor and
the fact that we can see into each
other's windows I would definitely vote
for for having something to protect both
their
privacy anybody else got anything to
contribute to the council yeah I think
on the balance of that probably enhances
and enables this application to pass
with both the resident and his neighbor
probably you know being somewhat more um
happy for this to go ahead so I'll be
minded to vote for
that c any any uh any other contributors
to this
no right thanks colleagues um having
heard everything uh that you read and
everything before you and the offic of
recommendations before us what is the
view of the committee on the application
I am now opening the floor to
motions
Council chair I'm happy to move with
officer recommendations with the added
condition of our obscure glazing and um
the I wouldn't want to requote him but
the wording that Adrian used with regard
to how to open the
windows thank you Council puler I'll
second in sympathy for clarity chair it
would be obscure glazing and the windows
would be hinged from the side so that
they would effect
not allow the the direct looking towards
the the windows if You'
like is everybody happy with that word
it yeah
okay right thanks colleagues um there's
a motion uh before us um we'll now put
that to uh the
vote
everyone happy with that right that's
uninus uh that's uh that's been accepted
with the uh condition for the uh uh
glazing thank you very much thank you
for your
attendance we'll uh we'll start again on
item
eight uh which is a uh officers to
explain the report appeals lodged and
determined again chair very brief um
update from us on appeals this month
we've just had the the one decision
which straddles two appeals uh planning
appeal and an enforcement appeal and I'm
sure members will have um read the
decisions relating to the retention of
um some cabins and then the change of
use of the land from agriculture to the
recreation and leure purposes at hag
Hill primarily relating around the um
use the the established use of those
activities and the structures so um
please read read that and it's useful in
terms of how the 4 tene rule is applied
in terms of the lawful development
certificate so members I'm sure will
find that of interest and with' only one
appeal that's subsequent to this report
that will be reported in January as it
stands so we're waiting for a number of
decisions to come through members will
note of course that the number of
appeals lodged remains high and we will
hopefully see those come forward in the
early part of 2024 although in respect
of the planning inspector at the moment
all bets are off so we just wait with
patience thank you chair thank you ad do
any members have any questions report
no right do we agree to note the
report
yeah noted thank you
you um as I have no urgent business at
this time we will now move straight to
item 10 um with the exclusion of the
public sorry you just read yeah I'm just
going to read it out yeah I move uh that
the public be excluded from the meeting
during this discussion of the following
item of business to avoid the disclosure
to them of exempt information as
determined in paragraph 3 and 5 part one
of schedule 12a to the Local Government
Act 1972 as amended by The Local
Government Act access to information
variation order